I don't vote
you votio dodo
photo
evodio
Cindy Williams star of Laverne and
Shirley has died she was 75 years old
[Music]
I have to be honest and say there are
times when I think
golly you know I want to be in the
Limelight I mean I don't think of it in
those terms but that that does kind of
well up every now and then but it's
nothing that is a driving force inside
me Cindy died in Los Angeles after a
brief illness her children Zach and
Emily Hudson confirmed the news through
a spokesperson to E.T the passing of Our
Kind hilarious mother Cindy Williams has
brought us insurmountable sadness that
could never truly be expressed knowing
and loving her has been our joy and
privilege
Cindy started her acting career in the
70s with movies like Francis Ford
Coppola's the conversation I'm spending
too much time together here no let's
stay just and George Lucas's American
Graffiti oh boy you don't remember
anything do you I wanted to do either
one of the other two female roles in the
film and they said no no we need you for
this part we I finally relented and said
okay and boy am I glad I did but it was
her role as Shirley on the popular
sitcom Laverne and Shirley that led her
to stardom
that dream come true
[Music]
she acted alongside Penny Marshall and
the Happy Days spin-off that ran from
1976 to 1983. it was amazing I mean just
what you would think it would be it was
like you were you know the prom queen it
was like you were just you know
everything you touched was magic but
penny and I we bought into it a little
but not a lot but I remember Gary coming
down to the set and showing us some
headline it said how many people had
watched the show it was like 30 million
or something how can he blame you for a
fight I kind of started it as you get
older things in your past become
treasures and you get sentimental about
them and you see the fullness of them
and you see the big picture there's a
lot of Treasured Memories there are a
lot of untrasured memories there
foreign
[Music]